our Series a more perfect union aims to
show us of what unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us and
communities across the country people
are getting creative to make sure their
neighbors don't go hungry roughly 40
million Americans are food insecure
meaning they can't always afford food we
visited one Minnesota neighborhood where
a simple idea is helping many families
in need every day when Jamie Hendricks
gets home she gets to work checking her
pantry and filling it up so what needs
to be restocked today so today we need
to restock some more of the vegetables
and some more of the macaroni type items
but this food isn't for her family it's
for her community in Saint Paul
Minnesota and what do you grab it now
for the pantry toilet paper the supplies
are headed to her front yard where she
planted the north and free pantry she
got the idea from little free libraries
where neighbors lend and borrow books
that she's replaced books with food so
many people took the free food she had
to replace her two and a half foot
cabinet with a seven foot one that told
me that we have a much bigger problem
but much bigger need in our community
than what I had even thought every day
when I come home and I check it there's
usually some things done when you know
people are a few days away from their
payday right before our rent right after
they paid their rent 20% of people in
st. Paul live below the poverty line
that's more than eight percent above the
national poverty rate Angela crush knows
what it's like to have to choose between
paying bills and buying groceries for
her husband and four kids now we don't
get paid for another three days so we
are at the pantry trying to figure out
what we can feed the kids since they're
out of school so what are you hoping to
get here today some breakfast is
something that we can make so they can
warm up when I'm at work right ruch
learned about the pantry on Facebook
here deal she's gone to food banks but
they have limited hours and some require
proof of income she says she and her
husband makes seventy five dollars too
much to qualify for food stamps having
the pantry and it being anonymous it
helps a lot it makes it so you don't
have to answer to anybody
feels shameful there's nothing worse
than only having some things to feed
your kids and not having what they want
to eat as a mom it makes you feel really
sad that they don't want to eat ramen
noodles or they don't want to eat the
soup you got but they have to because
you don't have anything else to feed
them it's really hard I don't mean the
ground okay I'm sure there's nothing
harder than to hungry you know it's
really has your life experience pushed
you to do this for others we grew up we
didn't have a lot of money that was the
same with when my daughters were young
but we always found a way to be able to
make it and to be able to help other
people's free food pantries have popped
up nationwide more than 700 are listed
in this online directory Hendricks
neighbor Rosie Toole sees the impact how
often do people come and take food it's
not only that they're taking but people
are most two three times a week bringing
stuff that's a kind of provides a little
bit of whole for people and not just in
the sense that there's something there
but that other people care and so that
in and of itself I think makes a big
difference if everyone did a small thing
like this for the community what kind of
world do you think this would be a non
hungry world that's for sure
it would make it easier for people to
survive and so many Americans are
struggling it's 20 19 40 million
Americans are food insecure but what
Jamie Hendricks who created the food
pantry said is so inspiring it's not
just the food that you're giving out for
free that matters it's the fact that
people care exactly
and that could uplift us all because it
wasn't free for Jamie in the beginning
she had to use her own resources and now
now more people are donating but it just
shows you how much a simple little thing
that starts with kindness just builds
and builds and builds really lovely
scent a great story thank you